Google and Yahoo both use goats to trim their
lawns.
There are more stretch limos in Glasgow than
in Los Angeles.
New research shows that, for luxury brands
such as expensive perfumes and clothes, the
ruder the sales staff are, the higher the
sales.
In 2013, police in the Maldives arrested a
coconut on suspicion of vote rigging.
Without bats tequila would not exist. It's
made from the agave plant, which is pollinated
by bats.
There are 20 million sea containers in the
world. The ships' crews have no idea what
is in them.
Being lonely is as bad for your health as
smoking 15 cigarettes a day.
The Aztecs wore necklaces made of popcorn.
Boys in Bronze Age Russia had to slay their
own dogs to prove they were ready to become
warriors.
Charitable donations of clothing to Africa
have led to the collapse of its textile industry.
A quarter of all the vegetables eaten in the
US are French fries.
The phrase 'pipe dream' originates from the
fantasies one experiences when smoking opium.
A study conducted in Switzerland revealed
that stockbrokers are more reckless and manipulative
than diagnosed psychopaths.
Stalin hated his own son so much that when
he failed to commit suicide by shooting himself,
Stalin only commented “He can't even shoot
straight”.
The mortality rate of pop stars is 1.7 times
higher than average.
'Misspell' is one of the most commonly misspelled
words in the English language.